dad trailers they don't stop this is the
weekend of trailers so we have yet
another trailer and now you get another
trailer review this time for Fantastic
Four that's right it was Fantastic Four
and then it was rebranded as fan for
stick now it's rebranded rebranded as
fantastic floor from fan forest a closed
marketing department through the new
Fantastic Four trailer we get more of
what's going on in this one ultimately
it's this company that's trying to
master interdimensional travel Reed
Richards gets brought on because he's
really smart and free guys you don't
know he's arguably the smartest guy in
the Marvel Universe
it's like Reed Richards dr. doom Hank
Pym those are the dudes right there 20
how they master interdimensional travel
and they go to this dimension that looks
like the nether realm from Mortal Kombat
crazy happens in that bank robber
guy from the mask that's what I'm known
from every time I see this dude in the
trailer I just think of myself it doctor
he's about to operate sometimes someone
does a role that's so completely sticks
in my head that's his but he's like I
want to know where my kids are at but
someone in the trailer says four of them
survived which implies there's the fifth
the fifth you assess is probably due and
then they start exhibiting these powers
powers you know and we're all familiar
with Reed Richards stretches like rubber
Sue Storm can become invisible and she
creates energy force fields and Ben
Grimm becomes a big rock man he looks
really cool in this trailer I was like
that's a good looking Ben Grimm I just
love the fact that he actually looks
like a rock guy and Johnny Storm of
course has the best power of all of them
he becomes a big Human Torch literally
becomes like a flaming man other flaming
men it'll like you opened it door and
you don't know how to close him you
don't know what's coming through what's
coming through and we see do and you
have like a metal face and no mouth is
he gonna talk at all you didn't sound
like Kenny from South Park Oh like right
here guys I feel like we've been trolled
cuz it was told to us that Doom is
actually Dom Chef he's a blogger and
where everyone was like what even myself
I was like that's a stupid-ass concept
for Doctor Doom I want doctor do
ultimately the last Fantastic Four
franchise wasn't good pretty much at all
but the biggest travesty of the entire
thing for me was Doctor Doom and this
one looked to be no different I'm like
you're making him a blogger that's
dumbest but you look at it and he
obviously is one of the ones who goes
through this interdimensional portal
with them by island earth would they
take a blogger but they're like alright
we need a crew of five to go through the
portal we need a scientist the muscle
the hot rod the other scientist
and the blogger it's blogger and time it
honestly you look at that ensemble I
just rattled off none of it makes any
sense but he's got to be more than just
a blogger for this movie otherwise why
on earth would they send him I feel like
there's something else going on guys
something we don't know yet guys this
movie is like a good looking movie that
just happens to have Fantastic Four
characters in it which basically kind of
a weird spin on the Fantastic Four word
universe what if we're looking at it
Fantastic Four as beloved as it is is
kind of cheesy
it doesn't always translate well to the
big screen I feel like after the last
hoorah people were like we gotta go
another direction otherwise just gonna
be the same that didn't work last
time so I gotta say this new take on the
Fantastic Four isn't a bad move I don't
think it's gonna put some people off but
I'm not writing this movie's off
completely it's a good concept and an
interesting looking movie it looks like
it's a well shot movie it's an
intriguing trailer I feel like there's
something else going on with Doctor Doom
I really hope he's not just a blogger
that looks like dr. Smith from lost in
space after he turned into the bug so
we'll see with this one I'm like
cautiously optimistic for this movie but
I'm like I don't think you're gonna suck
as badly as people probably think you're
gonna suck right guys so the new
Fantastic Four trailer have you seen
that what did you think of it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
gonna give you guys some explanations
first of all the number one requested
thing on my channel Twitter Facebook
everything a review of daredevil it's as
simple as this I started watching
daredevil with my friend he went on a
little bit of a vacation so he's been
gone we've watched like a few episodes
I'm waiting for him to get back because
that's the kind of loyal dude I am do
you guys will get a review of daredevil
when I'm done watching daredevil after
my friend comes back and we finished
watching daredevil and I'm pretty sure
the universe will survive without a
review of paul blart mall cop too
unfriended I do want to watch it makes
no promises but I do want to watch that
one it's hard to go back when the
universe just presses on like this like
all this stuff that's coming out like
trailers trailers trailers all like
talking about those so we'll see what
happens but that's just kind of how it's
been those are the events and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]